starfield may change rpgs as we know it
today let's talk about it
as bethesda game studios prepares for
the launch of its next big game
starfield it's teasing new info in its
into the starfield series in the latest
episode titled made for wanderers game
director todd howard in crew talk about
how starfield will try to quote take on
the next evolution of rpgs more
specifically the developers talk about
how starfield gives players quote the
freedom to create their own journey
through the cosmos adding to this howard
says bethesda's other games are known
for how storytelling opportunities pop
up for players beyond what bethesda
designed and intended itself and the
studio is leaning into this with
starfield this is awesome to hear
because i'm definitely guilty of
creating my own storylines when
exploring games like skyrim or fallout 4
so it's going to be really interesting
to see just how far they go with giving
players that freedom to create their
journey through the cosmos and don't
hate me but when i see that quote the
first thing i think of is no man's sky
the current version not the launch
version even though i had some fun with
that too because i mean come on
that's what that game is all about just
kind of making your own way
through the cosmos infinite amount of
planets
find your way any way you want to i'm
not crazy for that comparison come on
bethesda is also leaning into how the
game's companion characters feel about
your character the game will also have
an oblivion like conversation persuasion
system where players will have to weigh
the risks of what they say to other
characters to get the ideal outcome in
the video the devs explained that the
technology assets in star field are
severely leveled up it features face and
body scanning based on real world models
similar to how the game uses
photogrammetry for its landscapes our
director ishvan pali says the team wants
all the personal interactions with npcs
to be impactful and for the players to
believe they are real people i have two
feelings towards this excitement and
fear mainly excitement though
just imagine all the reports of ruined
relationships because the in-game
relationships
felt so real that they broke off their
real-life ones i can't wait starfield is
a game about the cosmos and howard said
he hopes players come away with grand
questions about the nature of their
place in the universe additional
episodes events of the star field will
be released in the coming months as for
the game itself starfield is slated for
release on november 11th 2022 for xbox
series xns and pc it'll be available day
one on xbox game pass just like all
first party microsoft games after
starfield bethesda game studios will
launch the elder scrolls 6 at some point
further in the future no release date
has been announced nor have we seen
anything other than a logo so on a scale
of one to ten let me know how excited
you are for starfield and in some
unrelated news ea play live the
company's annual showcase for revealing
new games as well as updates for
existing ones isn't happening this year
in a statement to ign ea said quote we
have exciting things happening at our
world-class studios and this year we'll
reveal much more about these projects
when the time is right for each of them
we look forward to spending time with
you throughout the year let me know your
favorite ea game in the comments but
spoiler i'm only accepting ea sports big
games and after you're done with that go
follow me over on twitter and subscribe
to gamespot for more of the latest
[Music]
you